let's draw a bunch of parabolic mirrors
and what I want to do in this video is
do a bunch of examples of objects in
front of parabolic mirrors and think
about what the images of those objects
will be based on how far those objects
are and besides just giving us a better
understanding of parabolic mirrors
this will also it'll hopefully also give
us a sense of how do we how do we
manipulate or how can we conceptualize
these light rays which will be a pretty
useful tool when we tackle other types
of reflective or refractive devices like
lenses so that's a parabolic mirror I've
drawn its principal axis right over here
and let me just copy and paste this just
so that I actually let me draw the focal
point too so this is the focus right
over here so let me just draw the focus
right over there and this is the center
of curvature it's twice the distance
from this point as the focus so that is
the let me make it as close as possible
so that is the center of curvature right
over there and let me copy and paste it
so we can reuse this later on in the
video I don't have to keep drawing it so
copy it all right so I've copied that
now let's put an object and I think we
did this in the last video let's put an
object beyond the center of curvature so
let's put an object here and the
convention is to use upward pointing
arrow this isn't a light ray it's used
to show an object and we use the tip of
the arrow to really kind of show the top
of the object and that's usually where
we trace our our light rays from but it
doesn't have to be there you could do
the middle you could do the bottom and
you could figure out what the image of
the objects going to be so let's do that
and when you're dealing with parabolic
mirrors it's easiest to have to show
just two light rays one that goes
parallel to the principal axis and one
that goes through the focus because you
know what's going to happen to each of
those when they reflect you don't have
to do any math there so let's have the
parallel ray that's the parallel ray
when it reflects the the parallel
incident ray when it reflects it will go
through the focus it will go through the
focus and then let's have an incident
ray that goes through the focus an
incident ray that goes through the focus
and when it reflects it will be parallel
it will be parallel and this is the
example we actually saw in the last
video and so
whatever light is being emitted from
this point over here in that direction
it will come back and converge again at
this point and we could actually do it
at every point along the we could do it
halfway this halfway point of the arrow
just to make it clear this halfway point
of the arrow same thing you have a
parallel it's something parallel will go
will reflect a parallel incident ray
will reflect through the focus and I'll
just do it for this one right over here
it will reflect through the focus and
then if you have something that goes
through the focus then incident ray that
goes through the focus it will reflect
parallel it will reflect parallel so
this point will correspond to this point
over here I think that makes it clearer
that this image the image of this object
when it's reflected by this parabolic
mirror will look will look will look
just like that so will actually form a
real image and it will form a real image
that is smaller than this original image
it's not so clear the way I did it over
here but you could put push this even
further back out and it'll be clear that
this is going to be a smaller real image
than that right over there now let's do
a couple of more examples so let me just
paste my drawing so I don't have to
redraw it let's see what happens let me
write it so here the image just so we
can keep track of things here the image
the image is real image is real and
smaller and smaller than the actual
object when the actual object is beyond
is beyond the center of curvature and
actually let me let me make it a little
bit clearer by drawing let me do another
example like that where I do something
big way out here just to make it clear
so once again we go parallel reflect
through reflect through the focus and
then we can go through the focus we go
through the focus and then reflect out
like that and there you see now it's
much clearer that the image that the
image is going to be much smaller and of
course inverted relative to the actual
object now let's do this again but this
time let's place the object at the
center of curvature so let's place let's
place the object
let's place the object right over here
so right at that distance that twice the
distance from from the vertex of the
parabola to the focus so we do a
parallel line these lines are the
hardest things to do so parallel
incident ray parallel to the principal
axis this is the principal axis right
here principal axis that's what this
line is right over here it's kind of the
line of symmetry of the parabola when it
reflects it will reflect through the
focus it will reflect through the focus
and then let's take another ray that
goes the incident ray goes through the
focus and when it reflects it will
reflect parallel it will reflect
parallel and my drawing isn't the
neatest drawing on the planet and
actually let me draw it a little bit
better than that well that's pretty good
let me just so that's the incident ray
that was parallel and then an incident
ray that goes through an incident ray
that goes let me them having trouble
drawing these an incident ray that goes
through the focus will then come out and
reflect right over there and they'll
converge and the way I've drawn it my
drawing isn't ideal but the way but the
reality is is that they'll converge so
that the image will just be in an
inverted same size version as this thing
up here because it's symmetric let me
see if I can read read read are this
whole thing so it comes out neater so so
far that looks good so then you want to
reflect you want to reflect like that
you got you're coming through the focus
and then you have another ray that goes
through the focus and this whole thing
should be symmetric and then when it
reflects it comes back out like that so
that makes it a little bit clearer so
this is the object and now it's image
it's just an inverted version of this
object the image kind of comes into
focus or I guess you it the the the Rays
converge at the same distance from the
actual mirror as the actual object and
it's going to be the same size just
inverted so that's so here the image
here the image is real and the same size
and the same size as the object let's do
a couple more of these
I think you get the hang of it and you
might want to try them out you might
want to pause the video and try it out
on paper because really and I think
nothing beats practice so let's let's
take our object
let's stick our object between the
center of curvature and the focus and
the focal point so if we put our object
there we could have a light ray that
goes parallel to the principal axis and
then it will reflect out through the
focus and then you could have another
point it goes through another ray it
goes through the focus and then it
reflects and then it will reflect out it
will reflect out it will reflect out and
let me draw it better than that actually
this is that's I should probably have
used a more precise tool when I did all
of this so let me draw it let me draw it
right over here
so I'll have the parallel one and then
it goes through the focus just like that
when it gets reflected I really should
have had a line tool for this to have
neater drawings and then array that goes
through the focus that goes through the
focus will be reflected out parallel
would be reflected out parallel and at
least for the light that comes from that
tip they will reconverge at that tip and
if you did it for every point on this
arrow the image would be an inverted
arrow that is bigger than the original
and it is beyond it's almost the
opposite of the first example that we
showed and so now the image is bigger
than the original so the image is real
and it is bigger and the image and and
the image will will will it where it
converges is going to beyond be beyond
the centre of curvature and you could
imagine if this was the object right
here then this would be the image over
here if you just trace the lines
backwards so there's kind of a symmetry
here between this example and the first
one we did up here now let's just do a
couple more let's imagine if the object
is actually at the focal point it's
actually at the focus so let's draw an
object there let's think about what
would happen so if we're at if we're at
the focus array that comes out parallel
will will go through the focal point and
come out
just like that and then here we're going
to you can't we if we can't have a ray
that just goes well actually we could
have a ray that goes through well that
that become you can't go into the object
so here I'll do a slightly different ray
I'll do a ray that intersects that
intersects the parabolic mirror right
over there
and the reason why I want to do there is
because there the parabolic Miller
mirror is essentially flat and
essentially vertical so you can kind of
imagine that the incident ray is going
to be the same thing as the reflected
ray so you could draw a ray that comes
in like that so this is a departure from
what we did before and then the
reflected ray will come out like that
so what happens when an object is at the
focal point is that all of the light all
of the light that's coming off of this
object in any direction all of the light
is coming off of this object in any
direction will all be made it will all
be made parallel and so it won't
converge so it won't converge so it
won't be able to form a real image and
it's not it doesn't look like it's
diverging from some from some point in
the mirror so it won't even form a
virtual image so here there will
actually be no image no image when the
object is actually at the focal point
and then the last case as you can
imagine is if an object is closer than
the focal point so let's draw that so
let's put an object at the focal point
so right over here and here just just
for the sake of argument one I can draw
I can always draw a parallel and
anything that any light that goes
parallel will then look to come out in a
direction that would go through the
focal point so it would go through the
focal point it would come out in that
direction
although the object itself is blocking
but it would look to go in that
direction it would be reflected in that
direction and then you can imagine a ray
of light that would have been coming
from the focal point or would have been
coming in from the same direction so you
can imagine coming from the same
direction as a focal point would be
reflected parallel in a parallel
direction to the principal axis in a
parallel direction now these two light
rays are not converging but they look
like they're diverging from some point
behind the mirror they'll look like
they're diverging
from some point behind the mirror so in
this case we are forming a virtual image
we are forming a virtual a virtual image
and the virtual image will actually look
something like this
and so it'll be larger it'll be larger
than the original virtual image so it's
kind of a magnifying if you were to go
to what do they call it a funhouse at
the circus or the amusement park or
whatever and if you were to get close
enough to a parabolic mirror it would
show a magnified a magnified version of
you a virtual version of you actually
let me draw that a little bit bigger
just because it might not be clear so
let me draw so if this is the mirror
that is the focal point this right here
is the principal axis this is may be you
may be it whatever object you can draw a
ray that goes parallel it will reflect
in the direction of the focal point so
it'll reflect out like that it'll be
black blocked by the object though and
then something that looks like it would
have come from the focal point from the
same direction as a focal point would
then be reflected parallel to the
principal axis so these two rays once
again they are diverging but they look
like to the human brain to the human eye
they look like they came from that point
over there and so this would correspond
to that point on the virtual image that
point on the virtual image so hopefully
that gives you some practice but the
most important thing it gives you some
practice dealing with these kind of
arbitrary rays that we're showing
emanating from the tip of this hour we
could do it for the whole arrow but the
reason what we're picking these Ray's in
these directions is that they're easy to
work with somewhat they go through the
focus they'll come out parallel if the
incident ray is parallel it'll come out
through the focus